hey everybody I'm backstage here with
Ian Bremmer you're a global risk
strategist i am i added a fancy sounding
name with Eurasia Group and you're the
author of superpower three choices for
America's role in the world and you're
fantastic on the panel tonight thanks a
lot how did you feel like a plant I
thought it went great
I mean got to talk about the book talk
about the world pretty seamless
nobody was too mean to each other
conversation not the world absolutely no
no the world is going to hell a little
bit right I mean we'd rather if we
weren't really talking about big global
issues I mean the fact that right now
we're in the 2016 election period yeah
we have candidates that are actually
stepping up because of foreign policy
it's like what is this Canada I'm
writing we don't care about for most
know anybody not for a lot of we
understand that things aren't going so
well right for us around the world and
in the book you outline a couple of
options that we have going forward three
options I can go through probably I
would love it yeah so indispensable
America is the idea that you know um
even though we don't want to be the
world's policeman and we don't do it no
one else will and so we have to support
our values democracy human rights free
markets we have to support our allies we
have to support big global institutions
that we created because otherwise going
to get worse is that sort of the bush
approach say that was the bush approach
after 9/11 certainly not before 9/11 and
it certainly is what some of the
candidates are talking right now
Moneyball America a second choice was
kind of what Hillary did as Secretary of
State
the idea being look it's don't promote
our values all over the world but the
Chinese don't want to become free
marketeers the Russians certainly don't
want to become Democrats and don't try
to do everything if NATO allies aren't
going to spend money
NATO's not that important focus on the
allies that really need us that want us
like in Asia and on adversaries that are
ultimately going to form the biggest
problems for us like China's a real
pivot to Asia
yeah a reset with Russia a you know get
rid of Qaddafi but don't try to fix
Libya because that's too much money
okay the third option is independent
America and depend America says these
first two options indispensable and
Moneyball both sound great but the fact
is we don't actually want to follow
through on and if you're not going to
the worst thing you can do is say is
talk big right and and and not actually
follow through and so basically that
says lead by example focus on American
values at home and and stop with all of
these commitments that aren't actually
working in today was Bill mark very
clearly yeah said that's where we need
to go do you know that we're going down
one of those paths right now oh I wish
we were going down one of those paths
now what we're doing right now is
neither of them we refuse to do a
strategy for the last 25 years since the
Soviet Union fell apart we basically
said risk-averse until something happens
and then we run and react and then we do
it again and that doesn't work very well
I don't know our allies don't like it
and our adversaries are taking advantage
of it and for the last few years what
have we been saying we say you know
Assad must go doesn't happen Isis must
be destroyed
who's doing that Russia must leave
Ukraine I don't know China must stop
cyber attacking us and you know I mean
this is a problem there's a reason why
Obama's approval ratings aren't bad
they're over 50 but his foreign policy
ratings are in the 30s as a reason why I
think despite the fact the economy's
rebounded Healthcare's rolling outs
pretty popular people spending money but
in terms of US foreign policy that
actually is the climb my concern is when
I look at the presidential candidates
today running for 2016
none of them convinced me that they are
prepared to take the leadership in the
commitment to stand up for Moneyball in
responsible so saying independence is
heart and that's what we can handle
independent is it at the very least it's
a challenge to other leaders to say you
know what I know we can do this prove to
me we can do more
you want to vote for the in Burma thank
you so much for joining us backstage and
check out his book superpower three
choices for America's role in the world
very interesting read and you know make
your choice take in the comments section
thank you much